Oh do I look tired yeah I'm tired just
got back from Canada after making a
bunch of rented videos to make you
another reddit video I'm actually
excited to check out low I I don't care
I don't care I don't care
leave your entries already closed first
picture my sister sent me this picture
of our star local Starbucks wow you got
to meet Naruto wow that's so cool
congratulations I wish I can meet Naruto
one day maybe one day I love when I get
the question every time what are you
doing here visit I'm here I don't know
why it bothers me so much getting that
question it's like I always have to have
a reason for my existence we're going to
Niagara Falls this is the drive bike I
don't just appear random places to
confuse people I do exist outside of
YouTube it is a thing I'm tired and
cranky I'm sorry
oh god you're trying to get me in
trouble what is this this is a great
artist by the way sir one Kornelia check
out loopy looked gay oh yeah all that
mr. B Sufis went down for the Lorax
all of Reddit wait a minute who are you
he's the CEO of Shopify I think that's
right and everyone thought it was
spotify songs on the radio during the
whole car ride songs on the radio
literally 15 seconds before arriving
home I don't understand this meme this
has never happened to me I cannot relate
to this whatsoever I wanted to dress up
my nephew as a zombie but he ended up
looking like a tired accountant good job
well done mr. breeze will plant a tree
for every and like how this subreddit is
Lilly this mr. beets not have a
subreddit half of it is mr. beast
I don't mind we'll play the tree for
every dollar you guys donate mr. B's
donating a hundred thousand plus a
hundred thousand and two I'm doing my
part Allen Walker donating a hundred
thousand and one I'm doing my part my
rich class
3,250 I'm doing my part me uploading
memes to spread awareness I'm doing my
part are you doing your part smash like
on this video slappers flex tape to show
you the power of flex tape I saw this
donation in half do not saw the tree in
half Phil do not do it mr. piece someone
please take this spot oh my god yes Elon
Musk's donated a million dollars
Elon son it's so cool
leave your entries in the Savera devil
fetus tomato innocent infant cutest
child juvenile preteen confused teen
troublemaker teen existential adult
responsible adult go with that I'll go
with that
sure sure responsible yeah when 20
million trees are finished growing paper
companies so anyway I started shopping
shop shop
hmm I don't need access to shop trees I
play Minecraft he's got two shakers
that's it League four Oh send him to
jail there's too much shadowy happening
look at that shin straight out of
Minecraft absolutely beautiful other
youtubers and Elon donating for team
trees nine year olds come on do
something piss my card doesn't work I
don't make big transactions Oh at least
how do you spend a million dollars just
like that how do you do that how how do
you mr. Reese to spend a hundred
thousand what kind of credit card is he
have I never spend more than 20 bucks I
have to contact at least five people to
make this donation come on Felix
69-420 thank you very much
69-420 I donated the funny number which
I think makes my donation more than
anyone's look even the country of
Ukraine what have you done huh after
observing how students buy food clever
dog uses leaves as money to pay for
cookies good times
the door but I don't think you're
supposed to be your dog cookies just
like just fi if FY don't do it trust me
they'll get diarrhea that's I'm
literally just saving your carpet then
everyone realized that Felix Kilson on
purpose so you can finish this series I
needed to stall for time all right man
there's so much stuff I want to do in
Minecraft I just haven't had time it's
that as soon as I'm done with this
minecraft is next okay I'm coming for
you minecraft the odd ones out
oh and Jaden they donated 3 good job
Jaden
they gave back there and mr. beast
winning money from the battle royale
thing epic that's cool finally something
positive on YouTube epic my mom dinner's
ready
my dad seven year old me my mom you two
can set the table my dad seven year old
me relatable it's relatable edgy anime
character please katana back in this
case his enemy how how is this meme
still going and why am I still a finger
that's great that's great me well then
will you please listen I'm not gonna say
literally all of it he is the Messiah I
mean this memes sucks but I do agree
with it so it bit flies boys when they
go to toilet
okay flippin kick flips of shoe wow
that's awesome oh he's got a ramp oh wow
if you're a non pee pee person this is
accurate can confirm this is accurate do
this all the time I'll buy you know do
you like my Halloween cast until next
May Peter pie becomes first youtuber to
hit 102 million subscribers thank you
guys so much 102 million has been the
number that I wanted most out of all Tim
trees government does nothing mr. piece
so anyway as that a plane if the Titanic
sank today a lot of this is becoming a
meme now there's boomers laughing at
terrible jokes listen I know I'm a
millennial I know I'm not actually a
Boomer okay it's just like I'm stuck in
between that's how it feels like the sky
is officially banned oh my god
look it looks up at sky one day ban it
ban it right now but sir its sky gets
into the why the person who made this
has small peepee pills me I have one but
at what cost the person with this has
micro peepee feel better
that's right I know sighs of all peepees
ask me and I shall answer it's my gift
in life when Felix sees that his this
meme is finally oh my god it's working
again uh-huh how do I do this how does
anyone know I have the power of telling
this meme that's beautiful
how to achieve checkmate in two moves
I'll show you plebs Ellen musk for
Treebeard
1 million trees I love him
girls on snapchat boys on snapchat
hey remember when I just uploaded a
video of me looking at at Instagram
filters for 14 minutes remember that
remember that video okay cool
me neither no I don't remember that that
was good it's a good video it's a good
video using a single format combining
nine of them Beck whoa my name is Rohan
okay digital artist you made this fan
art which is what how a city would look
like if PewDiePie on it
that's right utopia utopia bro land oh
my god that would be merch
everywhere and there will be no children
notice as there's no children there my
god I'm crying it's beautiful
Gen Z's solving problems created by
boomers boomers saying Gen Z are lazy
and useless yep
pretty much summarizes it what what
problems have Gen Z solved come on let's
get real here okay actually there are a
couple examples of that guy that young
guy here is 30 million to fund his idea
of cleaning up plastic in the ocean yeah
pretty awesome okay fine
one person did it whatever Toby let's
get the Lorax trunks okay
Tanner's meme I don't even know who you
are but awesome everyone who fails no
not November should donate one tree for
every day left in the month well I
haven't failed have you Jesse makes fun
of boomer humor gen Z humor trela radio
music the entire here it is again I
don't I don't get this has never
happened to me is it like oh good song
finally comes on but you have to leave
the car is that it sounds like a gen C
problem don't care
Pierce when nobody notices that he's
slowly quitting I made a Minecraft song
anyone notice that be quiet
guy in white so my dog can have one more
truth to be oh you hear that okay you
can pee on three now hey Edgar how much
did you donate it huh how much have you
donated you use the stinky little dog
say it say that you're stinky what I see
when I drop my food what bacteria good
me big PP I'm gonna say it big PP I
showed you my Rasengan please respond
the headband is upside down boomer the
image is me resume ur cringe this is so
crane got him mr. beast over 100,000
allen walker doughnut on 2001 mr. P's
there 2002 that's awesome
Susan Wojcicki hundred two hundred
thousand trees thanks Hayden okay
alright alright let's appreciate someone
doing good okay this is where we put all
differences aside handshaking was
invented in 1400s people in 1399 hey he
messed it up too no one talks about this
he messed it up too he messed it up
teria wasn't just me he messed it up too
there's takes two people to tango that
takes two people to handshake there
takes two people to go to the bathroom
okay one person poops and the other
person wipes so it takes two people to
make a problem think about that
planted a bunch about 900 little trees
and pasture any much but it's honest
work
you're a batch of 147 days too early
alright gwyneth paltrow shut the Frick
up you bald son of AB yeah I mean the
idea came from the subreddit I think at
least some well done it's really cool
honey give me the hair dry at boomers
ladies if a guy punched you do you think
you should hit him back yes absolutely
if a woman were to punch me should I hit
back yes
no remember kids life isn't fair
no but it's because women are not as
strong as men so it's not fair but also
women are as strong as men so it is it's
a joke it's a joke I made the joke I by
a grue costume I make a groom in that
meme is dead the meme is dead good keep
it dead it sucks
YouTube wasn't bad in 2005 people in
2004 that's a great name well then
bearded no stop it's a trap enemy school
girls in skirts are so cute is that true
are they actually cute you know what I'm
not googling that a married man but I am
ashamed
I'm truly undying meme no I am amateurs
what was that Punk amateurs
if this mean was good it would have had
the meme itself as on top of the face
but you know what you kids do what you
gotta do before mr. piece after mr.
beast what if I plant 20 million trees
in Minecraft is that possible can you
plant trees with like a redstone or
something like that
boop beep be read it inhales nice I did
the funny numbers guys I did
I'm 30 but I still have great sense of
humor
merge finally arrived in Australia
bloody love it mate I get it
nobody was shot in New York City over
the weekend so anyway I stopped blasting
it's so random how this became a meme
out of nowhere it's such an old episode
isn't it Poots before marriage I don't
want to kill PEP boots after marriage I
challenge any child to a fight and it
still stands my friends be careful a
girl can change you completely
Pierce becomes it hell he speaks in
Italian how do you think me and Marta
communicates this is the only way she'll
listen read it have you donated to team
trees foundation yet pills no olive red
it'd be a lot cooler if you did I am so
sorry for going away for three days you
know what
how dare I disgustin PewDiePie isn't the
only one with detachable legs Brown okay
that's enough vote is it possible to
learn this power just to chop off your
legs interesting I never thought about
it that way chop chop
that way you don't have to do leg day
sounds pretty good oh my god it's just
people complain I have donated I got
bullied into donating Jesus Felix now
that he's 30 how do you do for Loki have
you seen how young all these kids are on
YouTube I'm too old Matt I'm just too
old for mommy
paramount Pierce for daddy it's chicken
watching peers in China bro that's
illegal stop it we needed approval
teleport behind you like Slenderman
teacher ask me if you can't understand
student ask question teacher you don't
listen do you
you really don't pay attention to you
this stinky all right Joker memes stole
a thing apparently I like it I like it I
like it when you realize that pewds
phone camera looks better than its
actual camera sighs did you not color
grade it again yeah I'll blames I'm sure
Billy it's time you learn about money
and the importance of good choice well
done Billy
doneita team trees team trees I know I
know it's everyone else's fault that the
environment is fricked okay I know China
did all the bad and know everyone wants
the electricity across the world and all
the sudden co2 emission increases and
technically we haven't done anything
different than we haven't done before
but that doesn't mean you still can't do
good doesn't mean you still can't lead
by example thank you very much for
watching this video
more epic content coming up like
subscribe and all that stuff gamers yeah
that's it bye bye hegel hegel what you
haven't tried to pursue Malay turn saves
me after 50 million our troops fetch
down just now it's still relevant just
download it